[Música]
la decisión de transformar nos dicen es
hacer cambiar de forma a algo oa alguien
y transmutar algo a otra cosa entonces
es importante esta definición porque se
va a aplicar finalmente al resto de la
charla que vamos a tener y que se va a
tener también que aplicar para la parte
positiva y negativa de la transformación
yo creo que no puedo encontrar algo más
representativo para la transformación
que esta hermosa mariposa que finalmente
debe ser un capullo se convierte en algo
tan diferente y tan exquisito y
finalmente uno dice bueno pues si ese es
el poder que tiene la naturaleza sobre
todos los seres vivos en este planeta
como psicóloga y profesora que soy he
sido capaz de patentar y de constatar
transformaciones tanto en alumnos como
en pacientes
y efectivamente para aquellas personas
que creen que los seres humanos no
podemos cambiar y que muchas veces
escuchamos no las personas no cambian
pues les tengo noticias si si cambiamos
a veces involuntariamente a veces sin
darnos cuenta y bueno para ello yo
quiero presentarles algunos ejemplos
como psicóloga finalmente me voy a
dedicar a las personas y estos ejemplos
son precisamente de estas personas les
presentó a édgar es dar su estudiante de
esta institución estudió licenciatura en
comunicación
cuando yo le pregunté a édgar cual como
podría definir su transformación desde
que era estudiante hasta la fecha me
atreví precisamente a poner sus palabras
textuales para no cambiar el significado
de sus palabras y de sus sentimientos él
me dijo es el descubrimiento del arte y
la poesía en todas sus formas y
verdaderamente me sorprendió que édgar
que lo conocí como estudiante con todas
sus dudas e inquietudes que todos los
que hemos sido estudiantes aquí hemos
tenido alguna vez me pudiera hablar
sobre estas estos estos términos tan
exquisitos y elevados sobre todo
refiriéndose a la estética y al arte al
parecer édgar en una sala de cine puede
aprender mucho puede transformarse mucho
y cuando y él me decía precisamente en
esta anécdota que cuando una vez salió
de una sala de cine de ver una película
de un cineasta muy renombrado dijo salir
en ese momento de la sala y pude sentir
por unos minutos que el mundo es un
tiempo de gran belleza
gran sorpresa para mí muy grata sorpresa
que édgar esté en esta transformación
con estas características
finalmente édgar vive vive hoy en
bruselas bélgica es director de
comunicación de la empresa signis que es
una asociación católica mundial para
comunicación
édgar se ha transformado también les
presento a este la estela fue mi alumna
fue alumna también de esta universidad
fue alumna becaria y cuando también
hablé con ella sobre su transformación
yo acuerdo con estela sobre su
descripción estela era más bien una
chica reservada muy estudiosa yo podría
decir que hasta introvertida
y esto que les digo ya no tiene nada que
ver con las características de hoy de
steele cuando le pregunté a estela sobre
su transformación desde aquella época
hasta la fecha precisamente me dijo esto
conectar con lo que somos en todas las
dimensiones de nuestra vida no solo
intelectualmente sino también desde el
alma
esta es la actualmente funge como
directora general de la fundación don
bosco en cuernavaca
cuando ella me describía precisamente
aquellos momentos en los que se sintió
tocado y transformada me dice yo como
estudié la licenciatura como becaria
tuve que hacer mi servicio becario en un
área en donde nadie quería hacerlo que
el servicio de la fotocopiadora dice
paradójicamente cuando estaba yo en ese
servicio entré en contacto con otras
áreas de la universidad que yo
desconocía y que me di cuenta que hacían
esas áreas de la universidad dicen no me
cabe la menor duda que en ese servicio
becario encontré la vocación de lo que
actualmente hace lo que les dije en el
puesto de stella su parte oficial
extraoficialmente y la última vez que me
crucé con ella fue precisamente en los
foros de paz y reconciliación que se
hicieron a lo largo del país me lo
encontré aquí en acapulco nos invitó a
colaborar apartar varias personas de la
loyola
cuando les digo que las características
que tenía este la estudiante ya no se
parecen es porque efectivamente ahora
veo a este la librando codo con codo
diálogos conversaciones y negociaciones
con políticos académicos e intelectuales
que promueven precisamente la paz y la
reconciliación en méjico también no me
cabe duda que estela se ha transformado
considerablemente pero estos ejemplos
que les doy finalmente son ejemplos
positivos podemos también tener ejemplos
negativos
tenemos ejemplos de sicarios por ejemplo
que terminan con la vida más que
procurar la o preservarla por lo que nos
genera esta parte de nuestra evolución
pues tenemos estas personas que más bien
acaban con ella podríamos decir entonces
que estas personas más bien son como
mutantes que terminan con la vida no
entonces nosotros seres humanos siempre
estamos en transformación a veces aunque
no lo sepamos es claro que vamos a
cambiar de estatura de talla de físico
pero también vamos a cambiar en
personalidad y muchas veces y ustedes
pueden haber visto una persona que
conocieron hace mucho tiempo la dejaron
de ver y precisamente se cuestionan
muchas veces acerca de qué pasó con esta
persona que yo conocí era así y así y
así y ahora resulta que nada de lo que
yo conocí existe actualmente o no lo veo
entonces también trabajamos en el cambio
de la persona de la personalidad y los
rasgos que nos acontece
estos cambios muchas veces perversos que
tenemos se ven
ejemplifica dos de una manera muy
adecuada con el libro de don de dorian
gray de oscar wilde que se llama dorian
gray y que precisamente para ustedes que
ya lo conocen les recuerdo entonces que
el señor dorian gray tenía un pacto con
el mal y debido a ese pacto solamente
sus vilezas y sus canalladas se veían
reflejadas en el retrato pero él podía
permanecer joven y bello cual es la
metáfora que nos dice wild sobre estos
asuntos
bueno la metáfora que nos dice es que
precisamente el señor gray vivía una
vida bastante trivial y vacía
es decir
podía sobrevivir durante tiempo y tiempo
todos sus amigos he venido porque ya
habían muerto pero él seguía siendo
joven y bello
se caracterizaba por andar de fiesta en
fiesta de parranda en parranda de amores
frustrados de engaños constantes e
inclusive de asesinatos y finalmente el
señor rey cuando va al sótano y ve su
retrato termina con su miserable vida
lastimando el retrato destruyendo el
retrato y destruyéndose también a sí
mismo qué es lo que sucedió con el señor
grey bueno pues el señor grey usó la
fórmula de primero yo después yo y al
último yo que es finalmente la fórmula
perfecta para vivir una vida egoísta y
sin trascendencia y llegó finalmente al
punto central de mi plática que es la
trascendencia porque cuando nosotros
trascendemos también tendemos auto
realizarnos y cuando nosotros
trascendemos
pasamos precisamente de ser la parte
egoísta del señor grey
a la parte más bien colectiva
que nos permite aprender al universo y
poder preocuparnos por el resto de las
personas y del resto de los problemas
que no es un momento dado podemos ser
útiles o podemos trabajar sobre ellos
moverse más allá de las preocupaciones
individuales hacia temas o problemas más
colectivos o universales es lo que les
decía entonces dejamos de ser ese
egocentrismo dejamos de trabajar en ese
narcisismo y podemos percibir al mundo
precisamente como un colectivo en donde
nos podemos insertar en donde podemos
trabajar y servir y eso también se
representa en la autorrealización
les voy a poner algunos ejemplos del
programa del señor anderson cooper que
hay un proyecto que se llama héroes que
probablemente algunos de ustedes lo han
escuchado estos son gente que estuvieron
postuladas para recibir ese premio en el
2018 precisamente por su trabajo social
ella es maría maría trabaja en un
sistema de software para poder eficiente
es eficientar el desabasto de alimentos
en albergues que recupera de los
restaurantes o de los supermercados
entonces maría trabaja en eso florence
trabaja también en dar clases gratis a
ciudadanos inmigrantes que están en eeuu
tanto de inglés como de ciudadanía
norteamericana y flores para mí es muy
especial porque como ustedes ven no es
un adolescente o una joven como mariah y
sin embargo está trabajando para mejorar
la colectividad
y tenemos también a ricardo
que en latinoamérica genera a albergues
para niños y sus familias que están
enfermos y que les da precisamente
habitación mientras van a dar las
terapias al hospital y tienen que
quedarse en la ciudad entonces estas
personas finalmente se las pongo como
ejemplo de transformación y de
trascendencia de autorregulación
en las palabras probablemente del
presidente john f kennedy sería
traducirlo a algo como no necesitas
preguntar qué puede hacer tu país por ti
sino qué puedes hacer tú por tu país
este sentido de colectividad y de ayuda
que entonces ayuda a trascender a la
persona lo que les quiero decir entonces
es que para poder transformar primero
tenemos que trascender y para trascender
tenemos que trabajar con nosotros mismos
es decir el trabajo primero es íntimo y
personal y después podemos salir hacia
hacia nuestra comunidad para poder
transformar es claro que édgar
trasciende cada vez que veo una película
y transforma cuando nos puede explicar
la belleza y la poesía de una narración
cinematográfica es claro que este la
trasciende cuando ayuda a sus semejantes
a vivir en un mundo mejor y
definitivamente impacta y transforma su
contexto cuando intenta sanar a las
víctimas de la violencia en este país
se diga maria florence y ricardo que con
su dedicación y su esfuerzo pueden
impactar el contexto yo los invito
precisamente a que entonces hagamos ese
viaje interno para poder salir renovados
los invito finalmente a convertirnos en
bellas mariposas y embellecer el mundo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]